Robert Habeck Vizekanzler und der erste
grüne Wirtschaftsminister Deutschlands
seit Monaten ist er für viele sogar
Kanzler der Herzen er steht an der
Spitze der Politiker Charts ein
richtiger politischer Rockstar von den
Medien wird er oft gefeiert oder doch
nicht sein Image scheint langsam zu
bröckeln kritische Schlagzeilen Nieren
sich auf Twitter trennende zeitweise
sogar Harbeck Rücktritt als Hashtag hat
Habeck in der Energiekrise versagt
verraten er und seine Partei die Grünen
und ihre Ideale aus Angst vor einem
Blackout nicht nur die reservepläne für
Atomkraftwerke sorgen für Diskussionen
oder stimmt das Bild das von Haarwerk
gezeichnet wird vom Überflieger der
abstürzt vielleicht überhaupt nicht wir
gehen diesen Fragen in diesem Video auf
den Grund und schauen uns an was die
Zahlen dazu hergeben
[Musik]
eins vorweg wir wollen hier nicht
bewerten oder einordnen inwiefern die
Grünen die Bundesregierung und habe
gerade dies oder das richtig oder falsch
machen dass du bewerten überlassen wir
lieber euch schreibt gerne unten in die
Kommentare also Robert Habeck im
Dezember sein Amtsantritt da liegt er im
Politbarometer des ZDF bereits mit an
der Spitze auf Platz 3 bei der Bewertung
der wichtigsten Politikerinnen und
Politiker in Deutschland auf einer Skala
von -5 bis +5 hat er einen
Durchschnittswert von 1,4 vor ihm sind
nur der neue damals neue Bundeskanzler
oder Scholz und die vorherige
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel bald steht
fest der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine wird auch Auswirkungen auf jeden
einzelnen von uns in Deutschland haben
Gas wird knapp wenn nichts oder weniger
aus Russland geliefert wird Preise
schießen in die Höhe und Robert Habeck
Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz wird zum gefragten Mann im
Rampenlicht und super Harbeck der
scheint alles im Griff zu haben Hardeck
schafft es die Gasspeicher immer weiter
zu füllen natürlich nicht der nicht ganz
allein aber ihr wisst schon zumindest
wird die Geschichte manchmal so erzählt
gerne auch von seinem Umfeld und auch
wenn er echt viele schlechte Nachrichten
überbringen muss schafft Habeck es auch
noch die in einfache Worte zu packen als
Revolution der politischen Kommunikation
wird das Ganze gefeiert wenn er so wie
ich jetzt hier vor der Kamera steht und
irgendwas erzählt zum Beispiel als er
nach einer energiesparprämie gefragt
wird die kriegst du nicht Alter ein
Magazin bezeichnet habe sogar als Oliver
Kahn der Bundesregierung wir brauchen ja
habe Kati okay die sage ich jetzt nicht
er hat den Mum auch direkt Probleme
anzusprechen und nicht auf politische
Floskeln auszuweichen alles klar Habeck
ist im Höhenflug seit April 2022 ist der
ungeschlagen auf Platz 1 des
Politbarometer noch vor Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz obwohl er neben Olaf Scholz
auch eigentlich nur Copilot sein müsste
das hängt nicht unbedingt am
Armee an der Person also ist es eine
Person ist das auftretende Person so
dass man von einem parteiübergreifenden
ansehen sprechen kann nun hatte in den
letzten Jahren meistens Angela Merkel
diese Top-Position innen das lag
natürlich auch daran dass ihr das auch
gelungen ist dass sie in breiten
Schichten der Gesellschaft und das hat
man auch in den Umfragen gesehen gute
Noten erhalten hat
früheren Bundeskanzlern ist es zum Teil
nicht gelungen die sind dann auch
häufiger nicht auf Platz 1 gewesen
übrigens wie genau dieses Beliebtheit
Ranking entsteht was dahinter steckt das
haben wir schon mal in einem anderen
Video erklärt das findet ihr oben auf
dem i verlinkt falls ihr da noch mal
reinschauen möchtet klickt einfach drauf
aber das alles ist nur die eine Seite
der Geschichte in den vergangenen
Monaten gibt es auch immer wieder Kritik
an habeg zum Beispiel als er zur
Shoppingtour in die Golf starten fliegt
nicht privat sondern eben für Flüssiggas
ausgerechnet in Katar immer wieder für
die Missachtung der Menschenrechte
kritisiert wird später dann plötzlich
harbex widerwillige Rückkehr zum großen
Klimakiller Kohlekraft nach Kriegsbeginn
in der Ukraine Ende Februar betont
Habeck eigentlich sofort dass die
Laufzeitverlängerung von
Kohlekraftwerken nicht geeignet sei als
Lösung wenige Monate später Zähne
knirschen die Kehrtwende Robert Habeck
reaktiviert Kohlekraftwerke er
verlängert die Laufzeiten und vor allem
habeg schlägt vor
Atomkraftwerke als Reserve einsatzbereit
zu halten um im Notfall die
Stromversorgung stabil zu halten
ausgerechnet Atomkraftwerke eines der
großen kampfthemen der Grünen schon zur
Gründungszeit die Attacken kommen von
allen Seiten die einhalten das für
unnötig und sagen das ist auch mit
erneuerbaren Energien gehen kann den
anderen geht es nicht weit genug sie
wollen dass die AKW am Netz bleiben
nicht nur als Notreserve
Kraftwerksbetreiber bemängeln fehlende
Absprachen die CDU wirft Harbeck eine
anti-atomkraftideologie vor und sogar
die fdp-koalitionspartner in der
ampelregierung ist unzufrieden sie
wirklich einen mehr pragmatischen
Wirtschaftsminister und weniger grüne
Brille Habeck muss richtig Einstecken
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister ist
vollkommen überfordert zuvor hatte schon
die gasumlage für Aufregung gesorgt die
hat havix Ministerium zusammengezimmert
um gasimporteure vor der Pleite zu
bewahren auch hier gibt es wie Kritik
Firmen würden profitieren Kunden müssten
draufzahlen Robert Habeck der
shootingstart des ampelkabinetts findet
sich auf einmal in einer ungewohnten
Rolle er muss sich und seine Politik
verteidigen harbex Beliebtheitswerte
gehen im Juli 2022 nach vielen Monaten
erstmals wieder leicht nach unten bei
allen Befragten landet er auf einer
Skala von -5 bis +5 noch bei 1,6 er
bleibt stabil an der Spitze auch Mitte
September führt er das Ranking noch an
allerdings verliert er ziemlich an
Zustimmung und rutscht auf 0,9 ich hatte
die Frage vorhin ja schon erwähnt hat
Habeck mit seiner Partei Entscheidungen
der Bundesregierung wie
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine der
vorübergehenden Rückkehr zur Kohlekraft
oder Atomkraftwerken in Reserve die
Ideale der Grünen verraten sich von
ihnen verabschiedet bei den Anhängern
der Grünen kommt da im April noch auf
3,6 und Mitte September auf 3,5 also er
hat bei den Grünen Anhängern nur minimal
verloren hier muss man doch mal
differenzieren die Angaben aus dem
Politbarometer geben uns wieder wie
guthabig bei den Grünen Anhängern
abschneidet nicht wie in der grünen
Partei und bei den Grünen Anhängern hat
er nach wie vor Spitzenwerte das
bedeutet dass der Rückgang seines
Ansehens den wir im Politbarometer
gesehen haben ist nicht auf die eigenen
Reihen zurückzuführen sondern er wurde
von den Anhängern anderer Parteien
insbesondere der Unionsanhänger und der
FDP-Anhänger wesentlich schlechter
beurteilt als noch im Monat zuvor und es
gab denke ich in letzter Zeit ein ganzes
Bündel an Ereignissen die dazu geführt
haben dass die Bewertung von Robert
Habeck zurückging was wir natürlich
nicht sagen können ist welches dieser
Ereignisse jetzt anschlaggebend war oder
gewichtet werden muss das geben die
Daten nicht wieder denn das bitte
Zusammenhängen mit dem Erklären von
Statistiken ist nicht so einfach auch
wenn es immer Leute gibt die behaupten
dass sie das ganz genau wüssten aber die
Forschungsgruppe waren fragt für das
Politbarometer nach einer Bewertung von
Politikern aber nicht nach den Gründen
aufgrund derer die befragten sie so
bewerten Korrelationen und Kausalität
werden oft verwechselt ja nehmen wir
doch mal ein Beispiel aus der Statistik
um das zu verdeutlichen das ist
vielleicht ganz gute Schlaumeier wissen
es gibt Statistiken die zeigen dass die
Geburtenrate tatsächlich in Gegenden
höher ist in denen es mehr Störche gibt
also bringt der Storch doch die Babys
nee so mein blowing sind die Statistiken
nicht da besteht wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen kein kausaler Zusammenhang
allerdings zeigen die Statistiken einen
Zusammenhang das nennt man dann
Korrelation in unserem Beispiel je mehr
Störche desto mehr Babys das ist aber
nicht die Ursache stattdessen geht der
Zusammenhang eher darauf zurück dass in
stark industrialisierten Regionen
weniger Störche Leben denn dort finden
sie weniger Lebensraum und ebenso gibt
es dort auch weniger Babys weil Familien
sich eher im ländlichen Bereich
ansiedeln harbex wechselnde
Beliebtheitswerte können also auch an
vielen anderen Dingen liegen und haben
wohl nichts mit Störchen zu tun leider
könnte man sagen es wird dort Minister
trifft ihn die momentane Krise natürlich
besonders und Robert Habeck muss einige
schlechte Nachrichten rüberbringen beim
Politbarometer Mitte September kommt
heraus fasst die Hälfte der Befragten
nämlich 49 Prozent finden die
Bundesregierung Tour zu wenig um die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu entlasten zur
rekordinflation teuren Benzin und teuren
Lebensmitteln verlinken euch übrigens
auch noch ein Video vom Kanal ZDF heute
findet ihr oben auf dem i ich habe vor
kurzem vom kriegerischen Pragmatismus
gelesen vielleicht trifft es das auch
ganz gut dazu gehört es dann auch die
eigenen Ideale in so einer Krise ein
Stück weit hinten anzustellen vielleicht
zumindest eventuell haben viele auch
einfach Angst vor den Folgen der
Energiekrise zum Beispiel vor einem
Blackout im Winter davor bibbern mit
Wolldecke Sofa zu setzen das könnte auch
die Stimmung zu Atomkraft beeinflussen
für havex-plan des April 2023 zwei
Atomkraftwerke bereitzuhalten als
Reserve sprechen sich Mitte September
nur 32% aus 12 Prozent in der Meinung
dass es beim vereinbarten Atomausstieg
zum Jahresende bleiben sollte und die
Mehrheit 54% will Atomkraftwerke sogar
länger nutzen als bis April 23 was den
darüber die Angst die mit der
Energiekrise verbunden ist könnte den
Wirtschaftsminister natürlich besonders
stark Treffen in der Bewertung aber auch
andere Politikerinnen und Politiker
haben beim Ranking in Sachen Sympathie
eingebüßt Robert Habeck hatte die ganze
Zeit über ihn Politbarometer sehr gute
Noten seit Beginn des ukrainekrieges
sind die noch mal angestiegen das hängt
sicher damit zusammen dass er sehr viel
kommuniziert hat sehr viel erklärt hat
versucht hat auch die Menschen
mitzunehmen seit Mitte Juli geht diese
Kurve wieder etwas nach unten und es ist
auch relativ normal kein Politiker und
gerade wenn er
sehen muss in Bereichen wo auch
kontrovers diskutiert wird kann so hohe
Beliebtheitswerte dauerhaft halten also
halten wir fest Robert Habeck ist
mittlerweile tatsächlich im Sinkflug was
die Bewertung angeht er hat allerdings
auch einige Regierungskollegen mit an
Bord tut mir leid für die Metaphern aber
immerhin hat er sich nicht tanzend auf
einer Party filmen lassen das wäre ja
ein unglaublicher Skandal gewesen naja
oder auch nicht für mich zeigt sich da
einmal mehr dass sich die öffentliche
Meinung über Prominente schnell ändern
kann und man muss sagen ihm steht auch
keine einfache Zeit bevor wie es in
Zukunft um havix Beliebtheit steht hängt
auch stark davon ab wie er die
Energiekrise im Herbst und Winter
bewältigt er versucht eine Spagat
zwischen grünen idealen und
krisenpragmatismus das ist keine
einfache Aufgabe ich bin froh dass ich
das nicht gerade entscheiden muss denn
es da wirklich allen Stimmen recht zu
machen das scheint gerade unmöglich ist
bei Youtube eher schon überhaupt nicht
möglich als Politiker erst recht nicht
aber was wäre denn der richtige Weg und
es ist wichtig in Krisen auch ideale
aufzugeben schreibt gerne unten in die
Kommentare und mehr und links findet ihr
wie immer in der Infobox und klar dieses
Video hier ist stand Mitte September die
aktuellen Werte findet ihr wie immer auf
der Website des ZDF politbarometers und
große Überraschung auch die haben wir
unten verlinkt hier neben mir verlinkt
noch ein anderes Video aus unserer
politbarometer2go-reihe hier oben da
sind wir der Frage nachgegangen ob
wirklich alle afdler und Linke Putin
versteher sind und unten außerdem ein
Video in dem wir uns noch mal genauer
angeschaut haben wie abhängig wir von
Russland sind und was das für uns im
Winter bedeuten könnte danke fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal